Hey everybody, it's Mike from OrderFlows
and I'm creating this follow-up video to
the Markers and Flow Breaks training
that we did on on Monday. And the reason
I'm doing this is because, you know,
people have been asking me, you know,
how do I, you know, show me the steps
what I got to go through on setting up
Flow Breaks with Markers. Now, this is
specific to the Flow Breaks indicator.
Um, you know, again, you need Markers
and you need Flow Breaks for this to
work. These are add-on indicators,
add-on tools for NinjaTrader 8. Um, I
also suggest I have created a PDF of
this guide that I'm going to go through.
I'm going to also show you in real time
how easy it is to set it up on a
NinjaTrader. So, if you want to download
this guide, just go to
flowbreaks.com/markers/setupmarkersandflowbreaks.pdf.
It's the same PDF that I'm going
through, but then I'm going to
go through a live example, just show you
how easy it is. So, there's a few things
you need to do. First, obviously, you
got to open up a bar chart, then you're
going to add the following. Um, you
know, I didn't write down there add Flow
Breaks, but that's, you know, you you
you should.
Um, then you're going to add Markers
Plus the Force, and you're going to add
two instances of Markers Copy. You know,
one for the buys, one for the sells.
And also on your chart, go to the
properties, open up the uh chart trader,
make sure you have that enabled cuz it's
just easier to manage some of the things
from within the chart trader, especially
when you're trading. Um, now, sort of
one of the differences between Flow
Breaks and some of my other indicators
is with Flow Breaks, I don't use the
fast signal mode, okay? Instead, I just
use Markers Copy to copy the long
signals and short signals generated by
Flow Breaks. So, once you have your
chart open,
you know, pull up the indicator list and
you're going to add Flow Breaks, then
you're going to add Markers the Force,
and again, two instances of
Markers uh Copy, right? One for the
longs, one for the shorts.
Okay? So,
once you have all this, make sure it
appears down here under configured,
right? It needs to be there so you know
it's added to your chart.
Now we're going to go through some of
the settings that you're going to need
to adjust. So first is the account, set
up your trading account. Now if you
know, the first time you load it up, it
may say sim or may say playback. Um you
know, just click in here and find your
account. If you don't see it in there,
go to the chart trader and choose your
account from the drop down, then it'll
appear in there. Same thing with the
ATM, you might not have an ATM chosen
already in the chart trader. That's why
I go to chart trader and choose your
ATM, then it should appear in here as a
choice. Now this one that says day, this
is the type of order, right? You know,
default is GTC.
Um you can keep it at GTC or you can
change it to day. I just find day a
little bit easier to manage.
Um
then the next one, you don't have to
worry about trade size unless you're
trading more than one lot. Uh working
mode, I change it to auto so it'll take
automatically the buys and the sells as
well as work the stops and take profits.
Enable longs, enable shorts, make sure
there's a check box there.
I don't not using fast signal mode, so
I'll leave that unchecked. Now here,
6789, this is what you're copying,
right? You're copying the triangle up
for long signals, you're copying
triangle down for short signals.
Um the signal color for longs is blue,
the signal color for shorts is dark red.
Now the entry, how am I going to get
into the market for longs? I'm going to
get in at the market. For shorts, I'm
going to get in at the market.
All right, you have some choices in
there like stop or limit. I just keep it
at I just change it to market to get in
at the market. Now max and daily profit,
the default is 500, same with max daily
loss is minus 500.
Depending on the market you're trading,
500 might be too tight for you and
depending on your stops.
I change it to 5,000. You can change it
to 1,000 if you want, but again it also
depends on your
uh how big it is.
If you're trading micros, you know,
maybe 500 is is plenty. But, if you're
trading normal size contracts, 500 might
not be um enough for you.
And and, you know, depending on what
your stop is. If your stop is 500, you
know, or $400, then you're probably not
going to want to use that.
Um so, it's safe to to sort of
expand it.
Now, this is the second part. When you
scroll down the side here, there's more
settings in here. I don't use these
settings. You don't have to change
those. So, you can just keep them as it
is. Okay, so now let's move on to adding
the copies, what you're going to be
copying. All right, so there's basically
four steps in here.
The new marker's variable name will be
longs, right? Cuz we're copying the
longs. So, it you should change that to
longs.
The data series, you're going to click
in here, and then you're going to add
the flow breaks indicator. I'm going to
show you that in a second.
Number three, calculate, change it from
on bar close to on each tick.
Number four, I like to keep the plots
the same, so it's going to be blue,
solid, triangle up, and eight. Now,
these are the same type of plots for the
buy and sell signals on flow breaks. I
just prefer to keep it the same. So,
this part right here, this is very
important, the data series. Okay, so
what you have to do is you have to add
the flow break indicator. So, what
you're going to do,
um when you click on this, it's going to
pull up a box that's going to let you
choose
inside you know, the indicator, right?
So, you have to add the indicator in
here. Okay? Make sure
however you use the indicator
in your trading
make sure those settings are exactly the
same. All right? If you have it
different
then it's going to be you know, you get
different signals, okay? Sounds like
simple, but sometimes, you know, that
that's a simple step that people forget
a lot, right? So, however you trade it,
make sure the signals are the same. The
settings are the same, rather. So, this
one is for the buys. So, it's really
it's going to be copying this blue
triangle up here, right?
And then, you're going to do the same
thing for the cells. Okay? So, change
the name to shorts.
You're going to add the flow breaks
indicator again. So, you have to do the
same step. You got to click inside this
box and change it. Then, again,
calculate on each tick. Okay?
And lastly, change the plots dark red,
solid triangle down, eight.
Okay? Again, that you have to go inside
that step. You got to do that one step,
right? Let's just go back here under
data series, right? You got to click in
there, so it pulls up the box that you
can open up the indicators
um and choose
flow breaks and add it in here. This
time, it's going to be looking for this
dark red signal. Okay? So, the first one
on the buys was looking for the blue.
The dark red on the cells.
Okay? So, you know, just a a couple last
minute things
um which I'll show you
in a second is you know, make sure you
have the correct ATM for your market is
selected. Make sure it's on auto mode,
and make sure the correct account is
showing. Um just a couple of little
things is since flow breaks does not use
tick replay and Order Flow Trader 3.0
does, what you can do is run markers
with flow breaks on a normal bar chart,
then open a footprint chart
on the Order Flow Trader 3.0 and manage
the trades from the footprint chart.
Now, you don't have to keep the bar
chart maximized, right? You can shrink
the size. But, you do have to keep it
open, though. You can't close it. I I I
don't suggest minimizing it. I haven't
tried it with it minimized.
Um but, I just keep it open and I just
make it smaller.
Um
So, you can change the size again. Some
examples are on the next two pages. So,
for example, right? I have my
this one is running the markers, so the
signals will appear here, but since it's
wheat, will also appear on the footprint
chart, and I can manage the trade from
there. Now, again, I have you know, this
is basically like
you know, I got a 27-in monitor. I just
have it split in half in the sense I
keep one here and one here. Um you can
even make it
smaller like this cuz you don't need to
see all that back history, you know, but
if you're watching the footprint, you
want a little bit more space. So,
you know, those are some of the choices
that you can use. All right, so um you
know, what I want to do now,
okay, is
again, you know, take you through the
steps
on trading it with uh setting it up
rather with NinjaTrader.
All right, so
let's just go through it here. So, I got
my NinjaTrader, right, open up here,
right, so here.
Now, chart trader is open. If you don't
know how to open up chart trader, click
on the screen, control T, properties.
It's this one right here, right, off
chart trader, chart trader hidden. I
prefer to keep it on cuz then, you know,
you can manage your ATMs from within
here. You can change them, you can
create new ones, etc.
You have access to changing your
account, etc. Now,
in this case, I've already got
um
the markers running on here. So, you
know, let me just disable this, and
well,
I'll just turn it off completely. I'll
just start from a brand new screen.
Um
wheat.
Let's do a 100-tick chart.
I'll use my
white screen. I like white. Some people
do, some people don't. You do not need
to enable tick replay, so you can leave
that unchecked.
Okay, then here we go. So, I got my
blank screen. So, what I'm going to do
now is I'm going to add the indicators.
All right, first I'm going to do the
flow breaks, add that. Then I'm going to
go to indicator store. I'm going to add
markers plus the force, markers copy one
for buys one for sells. Okay, so you see
I got flows breaks, got markers plus the
force, I got markers copy, got markers
copy. Okay, so I got to change these
settings. All right, so
first thing I'm going to do, all right,
is go here.
Um so I'll change that the the right
account, the ATM.
Okay, so you see that doesn't let me
choose the ATM yet. I will come back to
that in a minute.
Again, you change that today.
Trade size one, now working mode I'm
going to change to auto. So basically
it'll take the buys and the sells for me
and then enable longs and enable downs.
Now
I don't use arrow up or arrow down with
flow breaks, right? It uses triangles.
So I need to go in here. So for longs
it's going to be triangle up, for sells
it's going to be
triangle down. Now I know it's blue is
the
signal for flows breaks and for buys and
for sells it's dark red.
Okay, so market market keep those as
market. Again, there's there's other
choices in there. I just keep it at
market. Um
in here again I change it. Again, you
can make 5,000 if you want if your
account's big enough. If you have if you
can only get risk 1,000 for the day.
This is the max daily profit and loss
where it will turn off stop trading if
you hit your max profit, your daily nut.
Um
or your
what you call it, um your your max stop
loss. Show P&L again, you know, it'll be
up here in the corner if you want to see
it.
I keep it on.
Now next thing I'm going to do is go to
the next step, right? Setting up markers
copy, all right? Because you want to set
the buys and the sells. So
default here you need to change this one
from my line change it to longs, all
right? Cuz I'm looking for longs
on bar close to change to on each tick.
I'll change the plots real quick since
I'm here.
Um, change that to triangle up and
eight. Now, this is the important step
here, input series. Just because it says
ZWE, you still got to add the indicator
to that ZWE.
So, it first it comes up it looks like
this. Go click on this folder that says
indicators. This pulls up all your
NinjaTrader indicators.
Click on order flows folder, find the
flow breaks indicator.
This is the default settings. In this
case, um, this is how I use it is the
default settings. Click okay.
Okay, so now it says flow breaks version
1.0. That's what I want to see. Now, the
next one I'm going to do, I got to
do the cells. All right? So,
shorts from
change that to
um,
shorts, right? Cuz first one is
longs. Did I make it long or longs? Was
it long, too? Should I say longs?
Okay, so longs and shorts.
Uh, let me just get something to drink
here real quick. Uh, okay, so where am
I? All right, so
and since this is
the shorts, right? It's dark red.
It's going to be triangle down.
Change that to eight.
Okay, eight triangle down. Now, again,
the important one, most important one,
data series. Okay, so I got to go in
here, open that up, click in here,
find the indicator flow breaks.
Okay, make sure it's added, click okay.
Again, don't forget to change calculate
on each tick. That's important. Every
step is important. You leave one out,
something's not going to work properly,
okay?
And
there we go. It's set up.
So, open up the chart trader,
control T or scroll there.
Um, chart trader, make sure it's turned
on.
Okay.
Click apply. All right, so here's my
chart trader. So, you can see up here,
right? Earlier, it didn't let me uh
choose the ATM.
All right, in here. It's cuz before I
didn't have the chart trader open, so
wheat, right? That's my chart trader, so
click on
the chart up here where it says select
valid ATM. Change it, so now it says
wheat. That matches my ATM. Make sure
the account up here says the same as
what it says over here. Make sure that
says auto. Okay, so now when we run the
playback,
you'll see it should start uh it's all
set up. So,
that's it. You know, it doesn't take
very long. Now again, you can keep it
open.
You know, if you got multiple screens,
great. You can put one footprint on if
you use the footprint or not. Um it's up
to you. So, you see it's been trading.
It took its first trade. I like I'm a
footprint trader. I read the order flow.
I like to analyze what's happening in
the order flow
to get in or sorry, not to uh whether to
stay in the trade or to get out of the
trade a little bit early. That's all up
to you. If you don't use the footprint,
then you don't even need to open it up.
But, you know, it's
the the the thing is, right? The order
flow trader uses the tick replay,
whereas the
Flows Breaker does not use the tick
replay.
So, by automating it on a chart that's
set up for Flows Breaker,
then it just makes it a bit easier to
deal with, right? Cuz people go, "Oh my
gosh, I don't know how to do it." Well,
this is how you do it. Okay, so it's,
you know, really very simple. And then,
you know, I have this on pause right
now, so let's just keep running.
Right? So, you know, if I'm managing the
trade, you know, I'll come back up to
the break even. Depending on what I'm
seeing here in the order flow, I might
want to get out. Right? So, it really
depends on how you trade. If you just
want to run it without using
um the footprint, then that's fine. You
just keep this screen open the whole
time. All right, but if you're using a
footprint chart, if you're using my
order flows trader software, which is a
different tool than the flow of breaks
indicator,
um this is how
you can do it, okay?
So,
you know, it's it's really pretty
simple.
All right, it didn't You saw it didn't
really take very long
to
set it up. So, you know, once you get
used to setting it up a few times, you
know, you just sort of go through the
process and and, you know, it really
becomes
um you know, very simple to do, very
fast.
And that's it. So, you know, again, I
hope you enjoyed this video.
But again, go to the download link that
I I put up earlier
to
download this guide that I put together
for you.
Okay, so you see there, right? got out
of the trade.
And then there's another
entry that it got short on, you know,
based over here.
Okay, so it took profit, then it got
short again because there was a short
signal
um generated just after that. So, you
can see that the P&L is up here. So,
anyway, guys,
thanks for watching this video, and I
hope this clears up some of your
questions that you had on how to set up
markers
and the flow breaks indicator. So,
thanks, and bye-bye.